cbs ran the iconic yet occasionally
controversial big bang theory from
september 2007 to the show's conclusion
in may 2019. instead of focusing on
families or co-workers the series put
the spotlight on folks that rarely get
to say in most big budget productions
nerds in doing so big bang made it cool
to be a geek and embrace whatever
aspects of science pop culture and
general entertainment spoke to you via
an ensemble cast of unforgettable
characters one of those aforementioned
nerds was howard wallace the horniest
and creepiest of the bright friends
while he often made inappropriate
advances toward the females around him
he did eventually find love he settled
down with an addition to the cast named
bernadette played by melissa roush
throughout many seasons we got to know
bernadette quite well as we saw time and
time again on the big bang theory
bernadette was a good friend spouse
scientist and mother however there was
one major negative element about her
personality that was never shy about
wearing its ugly head at her core
bernadette was a mild-mannered kind
woman who wanted to see those around her
live their best lives just as much as
she wanted to do so herself she didn't
always display these attributes though
especially when she found herself in
competitive situations no matter how
inconsequential she'd transform into a
determined and unapologetically harsh
person often slinging insults left and
right regardless as to who was around
her even howard wasn't immune to her
wrath finding himself on the receiving
end of his wife's rage more times than
he surely wanted to be despite all of
this bernadette's short views didn't
always end up putting just her friends
in the crosshairs she could also use her
fiery spirit in such a way that would
actually protect the people she cares
about driving off anyone who unjustly
dared disrespect them in front of her
she shows no hesitation when standing up
for howard and even defends stewart from
a rival comic book store owners bullying
given her presentation as a quiet
easy-going young lady they never see it
coming hence the hilarity of these
particular scenes
when provoked bernadette could become a
terrifying person that didn't
discriminate when it came to verbally
attacking other people this is obviously
not the best character trait to have but
it's aided by the fact that she tends to
use it in defense of the ones she loves
more often than not it only ever really
became a problem when her loved ones
were on the wrong side of her scorn a
feisty attitude is one thing it's
another thing entirely to become
obsessive to the point where you demean
the person you love most in the world
and it was something bernadette was not
afraid of doing if there were a single
episode that best encapsulated
bernadette's competitive nature it would
be season 12 episode 9 the citation
negation this episode sees howard and
raj becoming obsessed with the video
game sensation fortnite bernadette wants
to get in on the fun but there's just
one problem she's not very good at the
game she enlists the help of denise to
teach her the ways of fortnite but no
matter how much she practices she still
can't get better than her husband when
howard kills bernadette's character
quickly she responds with an obviously
embarrassed jab howard what i make more
money than you
the funny thing is that howard never
made fun of her for being bad at
fortnite he also had no problem letting
her play for a little bit to see what
the game was like for herself how nice
her competitive side wouldn't allow
howard and raj to have a fun activity
for the two of them to share she had to
become the best at it and when she
failed she had to find another way to
demonstrate her superiority over her
husband granted we're probably looking
too deeply into this personality trait
we know it's all meant for laughs
however regardless of how you feel about
bernadette you have to admit that
melissa roush's performance is second to
none even if it made the character a bit
unlikable at times
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]